[موسيقى]
اخبرني احد الاشخاص يعني قريب من احد
الوزراء
بعد ان اخبرني الرئيس سالني قال لي في
مسؤولين بدو يجوني شنو يعني شنو القصه فمن
سالتها قال لي كل اسبوع يجون اثنين
بعضهم يعني مؤدب
يعني كثير يسلم بس والبعض الاخر يجي
بطريقه متشفين وحدد لي الاسماء
[موسيقى]
ابرز الاسماء اللي زارته او استفزته برهم
صالح وقال لك انه استفزوا شخصيا قال لا ما
قال استفزني بس قال ما كان يعني
ما كان لا محب ولا كاره بس كان يسال يعني
كثير سؤال وزاره وزير السياحه ما اتذكر شو
اسمه
وزير السياحه السابق اذا راى باختيار امين
كمان باختيار امين
عندك مكان تزرع بيه يعني حوض كان منطينه
يزرع به وزارني
[موسيقى]
فلاح النقيب
ايضا تحدثنا معهم في هذا البرنامج عن
زيارته هو اتحدث عن زيارته له
زياره جماعيه مع السفير بول بريمر
والجيرال جورج كيسي قال القوات الامريكيه
اعتقد كان موفق الرباعي كمان
واحمد احمد شلبي نعم
كانت تستفزه هذه الزيارات استفزه موفق
الرباعيه اثناء الزياره
بماذا استفز يعني يقول كان يعني بعيد عني
وقف وكان يعني يتكلم بذاع الفاظ نابيه
وقعد ما قمت يقول حتى القنا درس يقول
مسكون الامريكان وابعدوا
[موسيقى]